so Zack Snyder tweeted out a couple of
images of the cape and cowl from the new
Batman some people are going to tell you
that you can't make sweeping judgments
about the quality of a film based on a
couple of social media images of one
costume those people are fools I hereby
withdraw my support for the Ben Affleck
version of Batman I mean have you seen
this costume have you seen the cowl it's
got an arched eyebrow what's up with
that he looks like Spock just discovered
something interesting about a planet
it's makeup ah mostly nitrogen captain
fascinating it was bad enough when they
itched nipples on to the Batman costume
now they're itching a perpetually
quizzical expression onto his face
hopefully they've made a bunch of
different Cowell's so we can just switch
and be surprised Batman or angry Batman
they can make an animatronic cowl for
sexy Batman so I'm here at the Warner
Brothers booth to sing the praises the
new Mad Max fury road trailer what
everyone is arguing you know is Tom
Hardy worthy of the role you know all
that matters is that George Miller is
back George Miller secret best action
director in the history of the world
look at the road warrior movies over the
Mad Max movies the action is so fluid
and so kinetic I love the fact that it
began with thousands of storyboards and
not a screenplay the ideal Mad Max movie
has no dialogue just cars racing through
deserts and crashing into each other so
I'm here in the sideshow collectibles
booth because I could not pass up the
sight of a carbon frozen Han Solo
life-sized carbon frozen han Solo look
at the detail you can actually see the
breathing tube they fed into the corner
of his mouth when they got this mold
very very awesome but there's one thing
I can't quite wrap my head around that's
the price tag
seven thousand dollars for not even an
authentic piece of memorabilia a
recreation 7000 up who has seven
thousand dollars to spend on something
like this more importantly who has 14
thousand dollars if you have 14 thousand
dollars treat yourself by one of these
buy a second one give it to me and I'll
ski I'll get you back